the nice mug invented by Glenn Auerbach
lets you drink your beverage out of a
mug made of ice and an inventor in
Portland has created a new type of
mattress specially designed for the
perfect night of cuddling Vsauce Kevin
here this is mind blow
engineers at Stanford University have
invented a microbial battery to create
electricity from poop the prototype is
the size of a d-- battery and uses
naturally-occurring wired microbes that
produce electricity as they digest plant
and animal waste and they hope that one
day they can use a similar system on a
large scale in sewage treatment plans to
create great amounts of electricity
researchers at Ike a four side tech have
made a polymer that has the ability to
repair itself
they cut the material in half and
without the need of any catalyst or
stimulus it fully recovers its
mechanical properties after simply being
left for two hours at room temperature
the applications for this discovery can
help in industrial electrical and
automotive sectors various construction
and developing biomaterials pioneer has
created a new AR hug navigation system
that superimposes information onto the
windshield it gives the driver the
ability to see navigation and other
important information right in front of
them without having to take their eyes
off the road it uses a laser in a
concave half mirror to project the image
it even includes information like
parking and restaurants that are nearby
so you don't have to get distracted
looking for anything I'm just a bird
laying on another bird sorry just Mayo
and Beyond eggs are new products looking
to replace eggs with plants the makers
claim the plant-based artificial eggs do
a great job with baking cakes and making
mayonnaise but have yet to master
scrambled eggs
yo bot is a robot that's solving luggage
management problems at a hotel called
Hotel in New York City with the push of
a button guests can have their luggage
sent to nearby airports you simply
choose your airport and then your
terminal and yo bot will send your
luggage before you get there they're
currently looking into creating an app
that lets you track your luggage on its
way and in the future they hope to
create a way to not only send luggage
but also people to their airport
destinations so yeah minor is a
minimally invasive neurosurgical
intracranial robot created at the
Maryland robotic center the idea is that
this little robot could suck out cancer
tissue from the human brain and it's
special because it could be used while
the person is undergoing an MRI
since the MRI maps the tumor in
real-time even as it shifts during
surgery the robot will be able to
effectively remove all the cancerous
tissue
harlem's Leon o of Greece created this
movement enhancing glove for the Google
science fair the idea came to him when
he saw his grandmother having difficulty
picking up the TV remote due to a lack
of mobility in her hands has pressure
sensors and motors that can adjust the
strength to the object being grasped it
created the glove so the wearer can gain
back the strength to do everyday tasks
like picking up objects Boeing's
unmanned little bird is the first
full-size autonomous helicopter and even
has the ability to land itself the
sensor in the helicopter maps the
terrain plans routes checks for a
landing site safety and avoids obstacles
most autopilot programs that are used
now are only for cruising and all of the
decision making is still left to the
human controlling the aircraft it's a
first for robotic aviation and since the
job a medevac pilot is extremely
dangerous they hope that this will save
the lives of pilots in the future
finally if you haven't seen this yet
it's an incredible video called box from
BOTS and dolly that uses projection
mapping on moving objects
I'm going to leave you with a guy
hitting an egg in midair with a
boomerang and then catching it and as
always thanks for watching